again I don't want to keep giving credit
to the internet gods but this story that
came out today a Saudi prince bought 80
airline tickets for Falcons the bird
that fly not the kind Atlanta by the way
side note a little weird that there's an
Atlantic a Falcon story
I got what do we think of an end before
I give you more on this there's this
quote I looked it up I did the most
research I've ever done
you know oh here we go Qatar do I
pronounce like Qatar Airlines actually
on their website has this you are
permitted to carry one Falcon onboard
the economy class passenger of an
aircraft and a maximum of six Falcons
are permitted within the economy class
if you go to business you can buy as
many as you want
eighty Falcons what do you get on the
Saudi Prince Falcons pickup well it
sounds like in Saudi Arabia Falcons are
like our dogs right that's what it
sounds like that's what I'm getting it
sounds like that this is a moment though
where the apocalypse is coming because
God is looking at this moment and saying
I made these birds that can fly and now
you're putting them in a bigger flying
instrument there some are that's why
this is the perfect ultimate example of
your money also side note for the Falcon
to put it on they have to wear a
seatbelt you have to put female Wow
they pay us on that boat on that plane
that does sound like a dog but you can't
train a Falcon I know nothing about
Falcons I know Falcons will turn on you
the second what question I just thought
of this if the planes going down do they
open it up and let the Falcons go out
yeah
to save yourselves Falcons have to